today our guest Kati naira is here today
to speak about her brand new film mr.
right and we've got movie fashion and
boxing gloves and this is thank you for
joining us today and completing
completing completing completing the
movie threesome I'm always down for a
threesome time for a threesome you're an
actress but you also have a fashion line
and your screenwriter how do you balance
all of that well the clothing lines just
jackets now so it's kind of that's
easier to handle but I love that you're
like it's just jacket so that's easy I'm
like I can't even pick out my clothes in
the morning let alone designing a life
jacket like it's nothing new it's just
the same the same silhouette so it's not
like a new collection oh I would have
jumped out of window a long time ago a
little bit about mr. riot this movie
here you play Anna Kendrick's roommate
can you tell me a little bit about
getting involved and what it was like
just being on set it was actually a
really fun set we shot in New Orleans
and when the Union people came to visit
our set they said that we were like the
happiest set because I guess there were
six other productions going on and
everybody hated everyone on a certain TV
show I won't say which that is no longer
on your character in this super quirky
movie is kind of the straight man I know
because it's so quirky you say something
ridiculous yeah it's rare that I play
this thing but it's true I'm sort of the
voice of reason yeah yeah he kills the
people who hire him how much of that was
improper how much did you guys really
script out we pretty much stuck to the
script and a lot of the other scenes but
Sam and Anna are great to improv with
and you know not all actors are great
improv errs so they're fun to play
around with well you know it's fun to
play around with us every week we do a
weekly wager and I don't know if you're
familiar with it yes okay last week we
talked about Allegiant it was the third
movie in the divergent series right
Tiffany remember what you bet I was at
the premiere in New York do you remember
what that was awesome you remember what
you bet I
I bet 36.5 the actual box office numbers
for divergent Allegiant was 29 million
which once again means what do you win
though if you win
bragging rights loser has terrible
things happen if you win like diamonds
but if you're not like who cares it's
true but it's all I got
this week's loser should comes from
occular nervosa who says the losers
should have to try to drink a soda
wearing boxing gloves no straw from a
glass a large glass okay that's a lot of
soda ready yeah let's do it come out the
big movie everybody has been looking
forward to this one we are going to make
our wager on that I think it's gonna
make 180 3.5 for Batman V Superman how
about yourself I'm still going big I'm
gonna say 182 though who do you thinks
gonna win next week I think she's gonna
win fair enough
okay so he seems like the winner great
idea um how about the movie itself
oh you're Batman are you Superman who
are you rooting for definitely Batman
let's see this just seems cooler than
Superman I mean just like the Batmobile
is cooler than like flying for the sky
with a cape
sorry core super well make sure you send
us your loser sheds using hashtag in the
YouTube comments below or on social
media I win even when I'm the loser I
win you can take them off if you want
because it's time now for today's topic
I really enjoyed the boxing gloves look
I think now it's just simple the fashion
is done you ruin a nice trend I just I
just didn't want those accessories I
would like so many the accessories and
fashion that I saw on the carpet for
Batman V Superman Amy Adams looked
amazing and the boys looked so good too
I mean Henry Cavill comes up and you're
like he's so dapper just in the like
very fitted elegant suit it looks great
I actually wanted to ask Katie because
of your experience in fashion here do
you have some movies that you could kind
of go through your memory and go I was
blown away by the costuming I saw in
that particular film definitely the
thief the cook the wife and his lover
you guys whatever you guys are both like
this yeah I find that most of the
costumes and like European homes seem
more interesting to me but even though
I'm not a huge comic book person all the
superhero films like even in Thor and
all the with the special effects or
different things that you can do with
that they definitely do make help make
the film or make the characters and
whatnot and but then all the classics
too like Annie Hall what my wife does
all the time I'm curious wait you're
married someone married you my wife
asked me yes well watch something new
Hades is like that's not that's not
authentic do I pick that up right away
yeah there's a lot of films we were like
wait what like this was not there in the
90s so your wife sounds smart
like I don't know why she's you're me in
person let's talk more fashion in movies
I love how much to like high fashion and
costuming and film overlapping even in
the TV world we're calling at what did
the costumes first Super Girl and four
flash and then you kind of look to the
Huntsman and she also did the costumes
for that now we see the beautiful
billboards of the dresses that Charlotte
my god they look so incredible well I'm
ready for something incredible because
you guys have been teaming up against me
this entire episode but not now but
you're going head-to-head it's time the
whisper game pretty easy the two ladies
will put headphones on music will blast
their ears because they've been saying
really bad things about me all episodes
in honor of mr. right the category will
be action comedy so you will guess I
will say in actually coming you'll guess
what it is
ladies please what do we win if we win
you get the leaf do you not like country
country please the first word is
Deadpool men in black - high five boss
you want to have sass car babe you're
like I don't know what
spy all right there we go
mr. right
so like she or she is good at reading
which is gonna that and on that note
we'll just wrap up the show I want to
say huge thank you to Katie for joining
us make sure you guys check out her
movie in theaters on April 8th mr. right
alright guys thanks for hanging out
doesn't make sure you click subscribe to
our show right over there watch past
episodes of movie through something
right there and make sure that you
download the Fandango movie clips app on
your smart phones join us every week
here on movies big fan of mine you know
she's not